young man that has vinick's
to the
phenomenal rats - to start him and now
you're saying do you know how to handle
it
privately within people around on my saw
a kid that was reaching out in the wrong
way of having the right support cast and
he was not mentored that way
he was not talking to a lot of us his
teammates at that particular time and I
would always complain to Mike about Amen
why are you going home so much and it's
like I understand that but every week
and it was going home it was going home
he kept going back home I mean you got
your boys sitting in the house just kind
of living it up they say a food today
there's a food tomorrow whittlin you're
not protecting yourself for what's to
come along the ride he allowed that to
take him to those dark places places he
didn't really wanted to be at 24 years
old it was just Mike's work I wanted to
do it my way and my way on at some point
this blast of arrogance I think overtook
me it's just a situation where you kind
of lose sight of it was right ahead down
a dead-end road
I always had a passion for animals and I
always had a dog a couple of dog well if
I can keep it my mom would let me keep
one in the house so I we snuck I had a
dog hidden somewhere took care of it as
a resident you couldn't have dogs in
your apartment
the housing authority wouldn't allowed
it but there was a clinic stray dogs
floating around here in our project to
West it was nothing for them we used to
come you know to get a dog and another
dog and fight them
so that was an old Brian today I've seen
a dog fight something changed I didn't
know dogs were reacting the way that
they did
bad news kennels started in 2001 it was
kind of technical training a box of
Virginia Beach Drug Task Force had a
drug sniffing dog there was a club which
auto dealers were app the dog hit on
this one car when the gentleman came out
to the car
they interviewed him they arrested him
and basically he said that he was living
on the moonlight road residence Devon
Bodie on April 20th was arrested on drug
charges outside this Hampton nightclub
based on that information the State
Police and local sheriff's office
in a search for why does this NFL player
have a property in this area of the
country it's really rural what's what's
he doing here I went to a local real
estate agent and asked why would an NFL
player have a property like this here in
rural Virginia a local real estate
person said if you're doing something
you don't want people to know about I
immediately called my boss and said
there's something here I received a call
from a deputy sheriff bill Brinkman and
asked for my assistance he talked to the
informant had a lot of information which
he gave me he talked about the
dogfighting activities on Vic's
residence he talked about how the dogs
were executed the dogs that did not
fight they called it rolling where they
tested the dogs for how vicious they
were and if they didn't fight then they
would kill him they were hung they were
drowned and they were slammed to death I
found a person who had claimed to a
fought a dog against Vick I went to law
enforcement and I asked them to vouch
for this person's credibility if they
were in fact a known dog fighter it
turns out that this person was an
informant for law enforcement for
dogfighting he would go undercover and
in exchange for him getting out of
prison once for dogfighting and not
going back to prison he was allowed to
attend dog fights as an informant for
the government
he had been to a number of fights at one
particular fight he fought a dog against
Mick we then had a group of state police
and special agents from USDA execute the
search warrant you had a two-story house
where the actual fights occurred and it
occurred in the upstairs it was a
pulldown staircase when you go up into
the actual dogfighting house you would
see some bloodstains on the floor you'd
see scratch marks when we dug at the
areas that the informant told us and we
uncovered the dogs I remember one of the
first ones when you would see the face
of a dog looking at you and his eyes
were wide open and almost looked like it
was just you know staring right at you
I was on the golf course and I just
immediately thought that everything was
gonna come crashing down I know that the
investigation was gonna be deeper and
that somebody was gonna try to figure
out what was going on
roger goodell a commissioner did meet
with vic in april and asked him straight
out when these allegations first
surfaced did you have anything to do
with this and reportedly Vic denied it
police investigating allegations of
drugs found evidence of dogfighting in a
Virginia home owned by Michael Vick the
Atlanta Falcons quarterback says he did
have a kennel operation but denied any
involvement or knowledge of a
dogfighting ring at his house number one
smoking gun was we interviewed Tony
Taylor Tony Taylor was basically kicked
out of the bad news Cal group he was
part of the dogfighting operation was a
friend of Qantas Phillips and help piece
Michael that he was one who had the idea
of building a house and a dogfighting
operation in Surry County according to
the charges it all began in the summer
of 2001 at Vic's home in Surrey
purposely designed as a stage for
dogfighting he was kicked out he found
all his stuff outside the gate
one night he came back and he was no
longer part of the bad news kennel
operation we approached Tony Taylor he
agreed to cooperate with us on the
dogfighting case he brought a picture of
all four of them at a dog fight in I
believe it was North Carolina two of
Vic's co-defendants were there to plead
guilty to operating an illegal
dogfighting ring at a Vic's home in
Virginia the men tied the Atlanta
Falcons player to some of the most
brutal allegations including killing
dogs that lost fights something that has
animal rights groups outraged from star
athlete to convicted felon his lawyer
says Michael Vick will plead guilty next
Monday to federal conspiracy charges
when the case came to a guilty verdict
there was a statement of facts of what
occurred and mr. Vick sign that that's
actually what happened and that was part
of the statement first that means that
he took part in killing the six state
dogs by hanging
drew hounding and the slamming to death
so your knowledge with the investigation
what other NFL or professional athletes
were known to be frequent member at
these dogfights I can't comment on that
it was literally like a Hollywood movie
set there were blocks of protesters
lining the streets everyone was vying
for the shot of Vic going into the
courthouse getting a seat in the
courtroom was so hard to do that we
actually hired local college kids to
start to stand in line for us at 4:00 in
the morning because we knew we'd be
reporting on the story till 11:00 at
night I'm a son of the south
I'm not ugly stuff in the Midwest
there's a side of the South I know that
I've heard about dog fighting long
before my other thing and people could
be naive about it this what they want
but Michael Vick did was wrong
criminally wrong but he operated in a
culture in which that was not all that
rare I remember talking to friends from
the South the deep south the mid-south
during this time and I'd say worrying
about dog fighting been around dog
fighting scene since I was a kid
dogs want to please their master now
you're putting this dog in this position
where it's going to be physically harmed
routinely and psychologically scarred
all because it's trying to please you
you're taking advantage of that and
abusing it like a kid right like a child
I think that people equate what he did
with child abuse I thought it was unfair
and justified don't even been made an
example we come from a culture we see
dogs and dogs and dogs we don't see real
treatment like humans we don't put
sweaters on them you know I mean I
thought Carlo chained on we see them as
dog that's what they are it's unfair to
our culture you know I mean because now
you saying that your culture you better
than us because you don't fight dogs so
you haven't done anything bad with the
dogs or without without
animal rights protesters target their
rage at an NFL star as he enters a
federal courthouse how's the family
disappointed and saddened we are by the
actions that Michael has admitted to he
is let down his fans and his team is
damaged the reputation of our club and
the entire National Football League Vick
stood without emotion as the federal
judge handed down a 23 month prison
sentence followed by three years
probation for his role in a dogfighting
operation it's just one of those seminal
moments that seemed to stop in time
people were just hungry to hear
something they wanted to get a sense of
whether or not he was contrite probably
one of the more anticipated press
conferences in sports history I take
full responsibility for my actions not
for one second when I sit right here and
point the finger to try to blame anybody
else with my axes or what I've done
totally responsible
I totally asked for forgiveness and
understanding as I move forward so
better I'm Michael Vick the person I
will redeem myself I have some
the lowest moment was when I had to tell
my son that I was going to prison and
that I was gonna be going for two years
he just broke down crying and only thing
I could tell him was that Daddy was
leaving the toughest moment of my life
reflect on everything that you had
everything that but you won't have and
what you're leaving wake yourself up and
let tell yourself to this river I cried
all the way to the prison I mean all the
way up and shut up and until I walked
got out the car and you know walked up
to the pegasi and put my hands and
handcuffs and
even then you know I still you know felt
like at some point this was just a dream
and I was going and I wake up but
somebody was gonna come and you know
relieve me first day was tough second
day was tough the third fourth and fifth
day when you started to settle in that
you're not going home
and you're talking to your family and
they're feeling the same way that you
feel it's just no form of jubilation
it's all sadness you know from from my
sinister acts there's no explanation for
nowhere consoling anybody was no way of
consoling myself being away from the
game when I was in Kansas and you know
the other places that I went you know
during my incarceration really gave me a
chance to reflect on what I was missing
and not from a football perspective or
what I was missing in my life and
there's so many things that had to be
tightened up and you know had to be you
know consolidated in my life and in
terms of family and friends and and
finances and I really didn't have a
strong hold on it but I wanted it he
would talk about wanting to get out and
would he get another chance when your
rights are taken away from you you gonna
grow that opportunity away from the game
of football away from my family really
gave me a chance to reflect then
visualize you know what the next chapter
in my life had to be about and what I
have to be predicated to and you know I
was committed to making change on the
football field and off the field
person I had to play the game with says
you know I was I was incarcerated and
you know I was I had a lot of items have
and I wanted to do something to kill
time and
when I first started to play the game
and I finally got a grasp of it and what
the game was actually about and I found
that it was a mental challenge between
yourself a opposition opponent replaying
I deeply fell in love with it because it
was another way to compete just to have
that competition in a different way you
know doing my circumstances made me
gravitate to the game and you know now I
love him more than I loved playing my
playstation game obsession in one
definition to me it's like the game of
life every piece represents itself has
its own actual movement and I think you
know life you know transpires in that
way you know everything happens in
phases everything almost has to be well
planned out and thought-out
I always compare a football to chess
when you're dealing with an opponent
whoever execute on that one plate which
is like one move per side and chess as a
direct correlation and if you make the
least amount of mistakes you win I think
chess made me a better quarterback
because I don't take calculated risks
you have to be able to see things happen
before they happen in that case it's
called a priest now every you have to be
able to see the defense disguise or end
up in the defense that you know they're
gonna play that's a correlation success
and taking care of my pieces and just
trying to have as many as I can trying
to make sure that I can destroy my
opponent I became wanting to maybe top
20 players in Kansas I it was a lot of
guys who who could play who was you know
very smart you know guys from all
different backgrounds just me being able
to work my way up from a guy who didn't
know how to play in 18 months beating
some of the guys who beating me and
taught me how to do certain moves and
taught me how to play taught me strategy
it was a different type of
accomplishment and you know that was
something I can walk away with saying
that hey I took some away from it that's
gonna apply to my day-to-day life and
you know I was extremely proud of
you
you